did you get any more perfect than this
perfect blue skies green grass that
never grows that perfect start button
right there in the corner all my
programs here on the desktop why would
anyone ever want to leave because storm
is coming that's right on April 8th
things are going to become a lot more
dreary and dangerous here in Windows XP
Microsoft is finally signaling the end
of days for the operating system by
halting support and halting security
updates that'll leave us more vulnerable
to attacks your Windows XP computer will
still work just won't be a very safe
place to live so what are you supposed
to do let's go find out
Microsoft really really really wants you
to come here windows 8.1 now upgrading
to Windows 8.1 will cost you it'll cost
you 120 dollars and you'll need to make
sure to get that DVD to do the
installation also before you buy you
definitely have to confirm you have the
system to support it of course this
place doesn't look anything like Windows
XP Microsoft has completely remodeled
the place with this Start screen where I
find myself right now everything's
really touch and tablet friendly but you
still can get to that beloved desktop by
clicking right here but hitting that on
the start button on the desktop just
brings you back here Windows 8.1 has
gotten a lot of improvements for the
mouse and keyboard user and will get
even more updates next month but it's
still a radical change of pace for the
old-school windows lover that's why I
think Windows 7 makes a lot more sense
for those living in Windows XP exile the
transition will be much easier you see
you've got this traditional desktop and
then the linear Start menu full of all
your programs it looks a lot like XP
though everything just looks more modern
the problem is is that Windows 7 is
pretty hard to come by these days
you can still buy windows 7 laptops and
desktops from select manufacturer
websites including Acer and Dell HP and
Lenovo most of the time they're hidden
in the business laptop section you still
can get support with
from Microsoft and the PC maker if you
don't want to buy new hardware if that's
where things get trickier Microsoft
doesn't sell box copies of Windows 7
anymore but you can buy it online from
computer suppliers like Newegg the
problem there is that you don't get
support from Microsoft anymore though
you will get security updates till 2020
of course there are other places to go
if you're willing to jump into a non
Microsoft world there's Apple's Mac
computer which runs OSX though that
might take some relearning but once you
get the hang of it it has a ton of great
features
there are also Chromebooks which are
inexpensive laptops that run Google's
browser
Acer's c720 chromebook is plenty
powerful and only costs $200 there's
also Linux options like Ubuntu but that
requires installation know-how and many
popular programs won't actually work
here I know it seems really sad and
gloomy here but I promise things can be
just as bright and green by packing up
and going to a more modern and safe
place and hey you can always take the
beautiful mountains and the clear blue
sky background with you